[Musique]
une fois encore on avait passé la
toussaint on a retrouvé ses longues
années entre les tons ces aliments
régulier des villes de morts aussi
peuplé que les villes des vivants des
villes de mort où nous avons tous des
parents une fois encore on avait passé
la toussaint à temps songé au cimetière
perdu ou l'énoncé face on tombe de
l'oubli gagne à tant de pauvres nord
abandonné le silence gagne un peu plus
chaque jour
le cimetière de sharon le dernier
cimetière de campagne qu'on trouve
encore en plein paris personne ne
fleurira plus le cimetière d'auteuil que
la ville a conquis et dont une stèle
marque seul l'emplacement
personne ou presque ne fleurit plus le
cimetière de montmartre le plus ancien
de paris qui étouffe l'ombre du sacré
coeur
les enfants jouent au parc monceau sur
ce qui fut un cimetière et les
promeneurs ont oublié que cette terre de
jeux plus d'une terre des morts
qui pense à ceux ci ne tire le plus
oublié qu'on trouve rue de flandre au
bout d'une courée d'un couloir et dont
le nom même a sombré dans l'oubli
a tant changé que l'oubli vient pour
tous est un peu plus tôt un peu plus
tard
attention j'ai que les pierres ou un
grand nom attire encore la piété
officiels sont aussi nu aussi solitaire
que celle où s'inscrit un nom de tous
les jours et qui chaque jour un peu plus
enfonce dans la bande au carrelet mort
dorment bien et les vivants oublie ceux
qui dorment les pierres s'affaisse les
cimetières s'efface il y attendent mort
sous la terre des cimetières dans l'ours
en eau sans présence s'en souvenir
[Musique]